reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution der geburt fast
gestolpert und sicher ganz schwierige
geburt ich bin für hauptschüler museum
die motorische ganzer schrank ich sie
ist eine normale geburt sehr smart ihm
wahl ist kein arzt der bn hebamme monika
erfahrung und ich denke dass der fall
eine geburt ist ganz tief in mir
verankert dass ich dann aber nicht
fahrer und priester wurde bin sondern
ein frauenarzt und geburtshelfer der
frauenarzt ohne loch aus dem wallis hat
seinen lebenssinn in eritrea gefunden
während zehntausende eritrea flüchten
hält tolle locher zur diktatur wie das
möglich ist davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
kam ein schweizer kennt der eta besser
als toni locher seit 45 jahren engagiert
er sich als arzt und entwicklungshelfer
für das land wir sind im süden wohl auch
reine pflege tochter hat koch ist
honorarkonsul eritrea es in der schweiz
eine diplomatische ehren funktion und er
ist gründer und präsident des schweizer
unterstützungskomitees für eritrea luca
toni locher findet es falsch dass schon
30.000 eritrea in die schweiz geflüchtet
sind wo sie kam eine berufliche
perspektive hätten und zu 80 prozent in
der sozialhilfe landeten in der hütte
fällt unser blick auf das bild eines
schulabgänger die familie erklärt locher
dass der sohn zusammen mit einer
freundin aus der region geflüchtet sein
in deutschland und hat jetzt das sind
und sie meine ältere das aroma stück
studieren
ob das stimmt dass zwei flieger aber das
sagt halten meistens waren es rück
malige anders schweizers deutschland das
studio machen
ich vermute ich den job oder glück
völlig passieren es aber einfacher
sozialhilfe wenn es kühler sind das kind
hat dein herz in chance natürlich besser
dass er gut die sozialhilfe dann
überkommt dabei wie sie
als toni locher 19 war engagiert er sich
in einer drittwelt gruppe für die
befreiung der afrikanischen völker von
den kolonialherren
jetzt sind die rita frei aber arm wie eh
und je eine privatwirtschaft gibt es
kaum
fast alles wird vom staat kontrolliert
was will seine kritiker sagen wo seit
jahren taxe hat dass das land eine
vorwärts rund 110 will es schlecht
regiert die stadt erkrath die chance
sein sozialistisches sozialist ist es ja
gar nicht und der autokratisch das ist
ein präsident ist damals isla bonita im
land gesehen und unabhängigkeit vor dem
land kämpft mit sinnen mit seiner
familie die hat er sie erlebt damals
wieder gebohrt wurden kreis
stattgefunden hat und weil ich das
vergleiche über die viele viele jahre 40
jahre lang szene einfach wirklich ganz
viele veränderungen und fortschritte
[Applaus]
seit 30 jahren betreibt loch in
wettingen im kanton aargau eine praxis
für gynäkologie und geburtshilfe
eigentlich soll der priester werden nach
dem wunsch seiner streng katholischen
mutter doch mit 19 erfasste in die 68er
revolution
ich bitte eines studiums aber verlieren
durfte sich also bitte
der silber schaffte der nacht und am
morgen am hobby sachs ist mit einem mehr
studenten damals die politische
finanzierte studentengruppe wahrlich zu
big city wir sind dann innerlich
kultfabrik tor gestanden und
handarbeiter früher versucht für äußere
positions- grüne und die herren da ist
das auch nicht komisch da glaubt dass
ich nochmals semir junge studentin und
versucht arbeiter bis bewegen wo sie
einfach ganz andere realität in excel
sind nach einem krieg gegen äthiopien
wurde eritrea 1993 unabhängig
die befreiungskämpfer von damals sitzen
heute in der regierung und führen das
land mit harter hand
in der hauptstadt dass mara unterstützt
locher die eritreische musiker
vereinigung
zusammen mit einem schweizer
klavierbauer organisierte die lieferung
einiger klaviere und flügel
zufälligerweise lagern hier auch alte
fotos aus der zeit des befreiungskampfes
als junger arzt organisierte locher zwei
lastwagen mit hilfsgütern für die
revolutionäre und fuhr sie durch den
sudan nach eritrea mitten im krieg und
nachts wegen der sowjetischen
luftangriffe traf locher die
guerillakämpfer im untergrund auf die
green ja bestärkte er die
freiheitskämpfer ihren weg zu gehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
natürlich auch das us-geschäft 60
einfach als jugendlicher revolutionär
hat stimmig sehe ich da eine idee und
das ist für mich eine politische
biographie ganz wichtig es sind immer
die gleichen leute immer nur trat die
lütz war unser großes opfer das land
befreit hat sind hüter der regierung und
hat natürlich andere aufgabe jetzt und
machen es eigentlich immer noch nicht so
schlecht
eine ziemlich gewagte behauptung um zu
zeigen was er meint gehen wir in asmara
auf die geburtsstation des zentralspital
woche bestreitet nicht dass die räte ja
viele demokratische defizite hat der
national dienst eine mischung aus
militär und zivildienst ist
obligatorisch und dauert oft jahre
andererseits habe die medizin deutliche
fortschritte gemacht in welchem jahr der
medizinausbildung sind sie in vierten
fort ein jahr muss ich noch machen
wie lange geht der national dienst ein
jahr dann ist zu ende
neun monate schule und drei monate
militär bei männern dauert der national
dienst normalerweise länger und vor
allem man hat keine wahl
während unserer zeit in eritrea kann ich
ohne einschränkungen filmen und ich
bewege mich völlig frei in jeder
größeren stadt gibt es ein halbes
dutzend internet cafés die jungen saßen
und tauschen sich mit verwandten in
europa aus cnn und bbc sind überall zu
empfangen
hast du verwandte in der schweiz
dein bruder lebt in der schweiz
und verschiesst
[Musik]
willst du auch in die schweiz
[Gelächter]
eritrea ist ein land ohne verfassung
fast die hälfte aller asylgesuche werden
in der schweiz gutgeheissen
das hieße die menschen sind an leib und
leben bedroht
locher widerspricht es gibt wirklich cry
und lieb und lama verfolgt die junge
mannschaft aber das geht einfach nicht
und das behauptet auch natürlich zum
beispiel amnesty international
diebe haben noch viele und die ihre
recherche sind ja so lausig inzwischen
zieht die die behauptet verzerrt durch
politische das ist völlig aus der luft
gegriffen natürlich das ist offiziell
gar nicht sagt wir haben offiziell aber
einfach schlechte recherche der in
eritrea wies eine ganz spezielle
geschichte mit eritrea haben will es mal
da ein arabischer frühling haben weil
organisierte das völlig in takt und
zieht es einfach richtig schossen auf
elitär und die brief verein ist jedoch
muss ich einfach sagen ich habe früher
eben stets sehr geschätzt das ist
absolut völlig falsch die zahl ist wohl
ziemlich übertrieben belege dafür gibt
es nicht erst seit kurzem öffnet eritrea
seine gefängnisse internationalen
beobachtern am abend besuchen wie ein
weiters internetcafé internationale
organisationen sagen eritrea sei ein
land ohne pressefreiheit ein überwachtes
und zum schweigen verdammt das land was
kann man im internet anschauen und was
nicht
eine position zum beispiel ja ja die die
website ja ja das sind frei verfügbaren
von jetzt gut zum beispiel erwarte dot
com oder das marino dot com
und es ist ja so dass wir jetzt ist er
nach zugesagt
der oppositionelle radiostationen aus
paris eigentlich bekannt ist die dosis
frei verfügbares gibt drei oder vier
fernsehstationen eine tube ist
staatliche ablauf oder opposition haben
sich nachrichtenlos nur würden sich die
jungen gar nichts dafür interessieren
wichtig sei diesen das soziale in einem
vornehmen viertel der hauptstadt asmara
besuchen wir eine der bekanntesten
sängerinnen eritrea bei tinga war
mitglied der volksbefreiungsfront und
kennt locher seit jahrzehnten
[Musik]
was meint die sängerin dazu das loch als
kritiker behaupten er sei auf einem auge
blind
man könne viel über ihn sagen sagt
feichtinger
aber er habe die verwundeten gepflegte
im unabhängigkeitskrieg als ihm die
kugel über den kopf flogen er habe in
den schlimmsten zeiten zu eritrea
gehalten und das sei was zähle die
sängerin gehört zu einem kleinen
material harisch organisierten stamm
einer der neuen ethnien eritrea das
fasziniert ohne loch
es geht die wunderbare anekdote dass
meine machen schlechte ergebnis dann
auch dann muss er am morgen ford to cool
sitzen außer frau spielten nach brüssel
und der gesetz ganze dorf das nicht so
komisch das ist einfach ein schönes
zeigt auch so die materie lineare
tradition sagt frau ist die dominierende
thema boni
eines der projekte die lockere am herzen
liegen ist eine milchsammelstelle im
tiefland mit velos aus der schweiz
bringen die bauern als den weit
verstreuten dörfern ihre milch zur
sammelstelle drei viertel der
bevölkerung eritrea sind bauern noch
immer frage ich mich wie kann ein
ehemaliger 68er der für die freiheit
kämpfte ein autokratisches regime
unterstützen
ja das ist aber in afrika typisches gibt
subventionen europa zunehmend autoritäre
führen das findet sie einig geworden in
europa für diesen winter was auf in die
sitzung in afrika danke buch zwar schon
die halter und autoritäre strukturen die
autoritäre auf das zwei wege kobe kobe
es gibt alle wochen in eritrea hinein
fort eine 2000 server dorfversammlung
tastsinn basisdemokratischen strukturen
dass man zusammensitzt und problem vom
torversuch zu lösen
zur basisdemokratie passte damals auch
das locker seine erste frau eine
schweizerin im feld unter den
freiheitskämpfern heiratete
[Musik]
unsere entscheidung hier im befreiten
eritrea zu heiraten war nach dem langen
kampf für das land nichts als logisch
wichtige anlässe wie eine heirat sollten
dort stattfinden wo man sich zu hause
fühlt
mit seinem engagement als frauenarzt hat
locher seither maßgeblich mitgeholfen
die geburtshilfe in harry dreher zu
fördern
ich werde wirtschaft kann man mit
elektrischen netz das
müttersterblichkeit kindersterblichkeit
rückgang mich und fritz sind einige vor
deine jungs waren nicht auf gewalt hat
hat nicht überlebt ist das übrigens jahr
weil man nicht suppe und die ich schon
und die eritreischen ärzte und
schwestern und hebammen das land
gerettet hat und jetzt mit die jungen in
der schweiz schweizer sind wir somit
verlorene söhne und das thw ganz fest
wenn nicht jetzt gesehen
der bahnhof in der schweiz voneinander
betrunken
er riet er war einst eine italienische
kolonie noch immer versprüht die
hauptstadt asmara etwas von diesem
zweifelhaften charme zum beispiel beim
opernhaus konzerte oder
opernaufführungen gibt es keine mehr
ab und zu wird der saal für die
übertragung eines fußballspiels genutzt
und manchmal finanziert toni locker mit
spenden ein konzert seine pläne
bespricht er mit barnabas dem
bekanntesten tenor eritrea woche bietet
den tenor für ihn zu sehen
barnabas wählt die eritreische
nationalhymne
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ist das nicht etwas viel pathos spiele
schweizer nationalhymne stand meistens
in beruf oder hobby ich singen sie hier
mitternachtskonzert im radio drs
zwei minuten vor zwölf jahren das ist
eben im auto bizarre geburtsjahr mit der
katholischen vergangenheit ich ein
ritual gaben
und obwohl jeder achte sieht hab mir das
haben alles wahnsinnig urkunde
aber ja das beweglich will es einfach
drin ist der musikalische ausdruck vom
innere lange verbundenheit mit einem
land mit einer mannschaft diese
verbundenheit ist stärker als ich
erwartet habe
[Musik]
in asmara lebt eine weitere pflege
familie von tory locher
obwohl er wenig gelegenheit hat diese zu
besuchen ist das verhältnis seit vielen
jahren unterstützt locher die ausbildung
der beiden töchter er ist wie mein
zweiter vater
[Musik]
er hilft uns seit langem zeit unser
vater gestorben ist
er ist unser zweiter vater seit 30
jahren sind sie es auch so ja ich habe
keine worte für ihn er ist wie unser
zweiter vater
ich habe tränen in den augen
das habe ich jetzt einfach glaubt sehr
berührt dass es ist zeit hat und das ist
das ist einfach wirklich emotionale
beziehung natürlich auch der frische
guter freund von mir der schweiz
gestorben ist ein botschafter der erste
botschafter der botschaften ihren sitz
in genf worden ist und risiken wie ganz
normale sie in gedanken an ihnen grenze
das dass ich so die rolle der uno hat
eine eigene familie zu haben blieb
locker verwehrt er hätte sich einen sohn
gewünscht
doch der zeitgeist war anders woche war
ein junger arzt der beruf verlangte
vollen einsatz verlangen seiner frau
musste er sich zwischen beruf und
familie entscheiden
die damalige 56 shift jurist damals
demnach auch das sagt dann hat das thema
ob sie das freilich zeit hatte ich mache
einfach übernimmt glaubt der cx arbeitet
ist ganz klar ob sie du hast dich
unterbinden oder du machst nur noch das
heißt sie hat damals quasi mit dem etat
billigsten brown als mühsam aufgabe
fügte sich der forderung seiner frau
gleichzeitig war jedes jahr oft mehrmals
in ried rea war ein nie versucht sich
auf ein erotisches abenteuer einzulassen
die revolutionäre moralisch sehr
stratmann damals also dass ich dann gar
nicht gut ab 67
mit frauen dritte welt quasi liegen dass
der pc charakteristische brauche mit der
humus male zu und machen richtig zunder
des schweizers umgedreht und ich habe ja
mal eine kurze beziehung mit der sie
ihre schöne frauen mit der berühmte
sängerin und sie ist aber labil ist
armenische gruppe warum material
organisiert ist dass sie nicht
feministin aber das sind einfach
staatliche frauen und die hätten ein
schritt auf mich zu und macht und dass
er mich sehr dass ich sehr schön
gefunden und aber am schluss ist dann
hat auch so sieht das mich dass ich mit
entschlossenheit bewiesen freiburgs
bliebe
geblieben ist ohne lukas große liebe zu
diesem land ein land dessen
italienisches erbe zerfällt beim und mit
seinem nachbarn äthiopien weder im krieg
noch im frieden nur fortschritt kann ich
nicht erkennen und frage mich ob toni
locher da nicht doch zu blauäugig ist
natürlich ist mich und das ist nun
wirklich alt 68er ich für nichts prinzip
hoffnung immer noch ganz wesentliches
prinzip und verlierer aus dem katholisch
oder aber weil es nötig haben im flur
fürs beherzt geburtshelfer sie oder
frauen aus über vor allem geburtshelfer
heißt ja stand ich also den übergang vom
tod zum leben und liebe zum tod sie und
ich mir da völlig blauäugig und
hoffnungsvoll dass er geburt kurt ablauf
und wenn man so eine land lang begleitet
der bruch zwischen die der grundgedanken
können und grundhaltung dass man die
wandse glaubt und das was jeder einen
schwierigen start machen
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution